hey guys it's max and vadim and welcome
to our unbiased camera comparison
between the iPhone 10's max in the
galaxy s 10 plus now both of these
phones have top-of-the-line cameras each
one has a strengths and weaknesses and
we typically do camera comparisons and
give you guys our honest opinions and
point out different things but this time
we decided to take it a step further
make it as unbiased as possible and so I
went out and took a series of images
that were gonna be comparing and Vadim
has not even seen them so he's gonna be
looking at them side-by-side letting us
know which one he likes better and why
so if you guys want to join me go ahead
and grab a pen and paper or the Notes
app and is write down for each image if
you like a or B better yeah but at the
end we will see and I set this up in a
way that in the beginning it's not
really noticeable which one is which at
the end it's more noticeable if you do a
lot of these tests like we do there are
certain hints so I wanted to make sure
that's not gonna affect your decision
its no choices at all so let's get into
it alright so in this first one the
colors are popping more on a and B is a
little bit more flat but I kind of like
the detail in be compared to a and a has
this really weird halo effect like if
you see around this flower right here
there's this weird halo and in the
window screen there's some oddness going
on this one doesn't have noticed that it
yeah yeah this one doesn't have any of
that so I think I would rather choose B
and I'd probably bring up the saturation
a little bit so this next one is using
the telephoto lens zoomed in all the way
so we can see what kind of detail what
kind of Minju we get if you're trying to
get as close to something as possible
okay so I think I'm going with B because
I could definitely see a lot more detail
and be just in everything this just
looks a little bit fuzzy noisy and just
less detailed so this next one is taken
really late at night so it's a very dark
image yeah what do you think right so in
this one I think I'm going with B
because a is just a little bit
oversaturated and if you look back here
it's all fuzzy and these trees right
here and this one's actually a little
bit more detailed back there so I think
I'm going with B on this one for sure
this one is really really early in the
morning so both of them are making the
scene kind of brighter than it actually
was which one do you like better okay so
I think I'm going with a because the B
looks a little bit too cool you can see
just how blue
looks and I think everything's a little
bit sharper on a as well so definitely a
this one's also before sunrise so was
quite dark originally what do you think
okay so I'm noticing that the kind of
holds these these colors right here the
blue and the yellow kind of holds them
they're not overexposed they look nice
but all in all I think a is the better
photo it looks nice and bright the white
balance looks good there's looks to be
more detail as well be looks a little
bit too blue and a little less detail I
think so I'm going with a this is a
really difficult situation as far as
shadows and highlights and this one I'm
seeing a little bit of overexposure
right here in the side of the house I
think it's a little bit overexposed this
one actually holds the detail there and
as far as I can see it looks a little
bit brighter like the detail and the
trees is a little bit brighter it pops
more I think it might have a little bit
more color too so I think I'm going with
a this one's pretty obvious there's a
lot more detail in a B looks a little
bit just not as much detail and I like
how is brighter just looks a lot better
if he just looks a little bit too dim 8
for sure on this one here's our first
selfie it was really really dark in this
room almost no light so this is like a
really low light selfie these lights in
the background are really distracting
they're way overexposed and your faces
also looks a little bit washed out a
little bit overexposed B looks a little
on the dim side and I think it has a
little bit more noise but I think I'd
rather go with B just to get away from
the overexposure on that lamp another
really difficult lighting situation you
shouldn't take selfies like this and a
couple years ago your selfie would be
horrific but both these did a great job
what do you like better this one's a
little bit tough but to be honest a is
like a little bit overexposed the shirt
just looks like it has a lot of noise in
it and B is a little bit too cool but I
think I could work with B more than I
work with a and this one I'm seeing more
detail on B if you look at a the facial
hair the hair everything looks a little
bit just fuzzy a little bit blurry just
not as detailed and I think the exposure
is overall better on B as well it just
looks nice and sharp so be for sure on
this one and for this one if you're a
real estate agent and you're shooting
photos with your phone which one would
you choose and why this is a very
difficult lighting situation by the way
I think B for sure
and a right behind the couch it's
extremely underexposed it's so dark it's
way too warm B looks more like natural
light and overall it's just very very
even and balanced so I'm gonna choose B
and now we have our first portrait mode
shot which one do you think looks better
overall honestly I kind of like the look
of a it looks like it's a little bit
using a wider lens but it looks better
to be honest it looks more detailed a
lot more detail on the face the the
sweaters it's really detailed beats it's
kind of like a little bit blurry
looks like there's not as much detail
and the face either it's just really
flat too I'm gonna go with a and we have
another portrait shot this is another
tough mixed lighting situation which one
do you like better
I'm thinking a to be honest B is a
little bit too warm and it's really
fuzzy like you could see the skin it's
kind of like got this pasty kind of
thing going on so I'm choosing a one
more time and now we're gonna compare
the panoramas now I don't have these
side-by-side because they are panoramas
but take a look at the first one and
then the second one see what you like
better so here's a K and there is B okay
interesting
honestly I'm diggin a better B looks a
little bit too dim it's underexposed and
a just looks nice and bright looks
detailed B looks I guess less detailed
so a for sure and our last shot here if
I saved it for last because it's going
to be obvious so we have two shots here
in a coffee shop one is right where I
was standing and the other one is I was
also standing in the same place but as
you can tell it's much wider
so which one do you like better well
obviously a like it's got so much in the
frame and I'm really surprised by how
little distortion there is for an
ultra-wide lens compared to be you could
just see everything and just see
everything on the wall got those wheels
in the background I think looks amazing
so a for sure I would vote eight as well
and then we're gonna count up and let
you know how much you got here in a
second but I do want to mention that the
s10 plus does have the advantage of
having the ultra wide lens now I took
probably four or five different shots
with the ultra wide some of them were
not better with the ultra wide so you
have to be careful when you're using it
in a situation where it looks good or
you don't have the space it's super
handy to have and there's it's awesome
that it has and I wish that iPhone had
it as well we just added all of those up
Vadim what did you get so I got eight
for eight and I got seven for B so it's
really close so a was the s10 plus the
Samsung B was the 10s max so you did get
one more for the Samsung SN plus I think
Samsung did a fantastic job
and they made a lot of improvements from
the note 9 which was quite a bit behind
the iPhone now jumping up if you joined
us for this unbiased comparison let us
know the results that you got in the
comment section below we want to hear
your guys's opinions of course all this
is subjective based on your preferences
make sure you guys subscribe and enable
those notifications so you guys don't
miss out on future videos this man Max
and Vadim with max tech and we'll see
you in the next video peace
[Music]